hi Adam yes I can give you an update
I've just heard from a government source
that the vote will be pulled this
afternoon in that statement in the House
of Commons through so may is going to
pull that vote which we had expected on
Tuesday that means the vote will be
delayed so I've had it confirmed by a
government source that that is the plan
for this afternoon we're waiting
official confirmation from Theresa May
and Downing Street the Prime Minister
but at the moment that's what I'm
hearing from my source at the vote is
going to be delayed and she will make a
statement in the House of Commons later
on presumably to explain to him please
what the next steps will be and exactly
why she has decided to delay this
crucial vote McCann thank you for that
breaking news at a breaking news here on
sky the votes of the meaningful vote won
by Gina Miller and others in the Supreme
Court is going to be delayed that's the
news we have from our government sources
mrs. may to confirm that in an
announcement to Parliament at 3:30 this
afternoon let's get a reaction of Beth
Wrigley Beth yeah so it's just being
confirmed and some of my cabinet sources
coming back saying in that conference
call it was decided to delay the vote
look I think there's a big group in her
cabinet are hugely relieved people that
would be loyal to her looking into the
abyss and thinking this vote goes ahead
labor could table that confidence motion
in her government and then would the
letters go in from the brexit ears
calling for a leadership bid as well and
so they're trying to buy some more time
yet again